nos dicen gráfica el círculo con centro
en menos 51 y que pasa por el punto
menos 2 menos 3 muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos está digamos este ejercicio en
que anna academia en donde podemos
nosotros mover este digamos el centro de
este círculo verdad podemos moverlo a lo
largo y ancho de este plano ordenado
verdad y también tenemos la posibilidad
de ampliar el radio de este círculo o
disminuirlo verdad entonces la idea
primero vamos a centrar este círculo en
menos 51 así que vamos a mover nuestro
centro al menos 5,1 y luego vamos a
mover este digamos el radio de nuestro
círculo de tal suerte que el punto menos
2 menos 3 se encuentre
el círculo entonces el punto sería menos
2 menos 3 es justamente este punto que
se está marcando aquí al menos 2 menos 3
y justamente este es el círculo que nos
piden que graphic hemos ahora si
tuviéramos la curiosidad de saber cuál
es el radio podríamos ver que el punto
que tenemos aquí verdad es justamente el
punto 0,1 verdad se encuentra sobre este
círculo y entonces si calculamos la
distancia del centro a este punto es
justamente 1 2 3 4 5 verdad entonces el
radio de este círculo es 5 pero bueno no
para resolver el ejercicio no sabía que
encontrar el radio podemos comprobar
nuestra respuesta y es correcto hagamos
un ejercicio más gráfica el círculo con
centro en 0 menos 3 y que tiene un radio
de 6 unidades así que vamos a mover el
centro al cero
-3 verdad 0 - 3 y ahora vamos a extender
el radio hasta este momento tenemos un
radio de 1 verdad por ejemplo este punto
que está a la derecha se encuentra en el
círculo y dista 1 del centro entonces
podemos ampliarlo a 2 3 4 5 y 6 muy bien
aquí tenemos el centro en 0 menos 3 y
tiene un radio de 6 unidades y es
correcto